golden lions epinal 16 novembre 2018
l'attaquant aux cheveux rouges
mais quelle biron va faire des dégâts
dans la défense spinalienne lors de ce
septième tour de la coupe de france
epinal s'en sortira ismaël gace le
capitaine s'en souvient encore
souviendrai une parole du code qui lui a
dit et vient chez nous pour vivre une
aventure de coupe de france et il a
écouté les venus chez nous et je l'en
remercie
c'est vrai que il nous avait fait
tellement mal avec avec le golden league
c'est un garçon qui est pétri de
qualités générosité aussi après un essai
infructueux en ligue 2 ajaccio il pose
ses valises à epinal en juillet 2019
il se frotte au club rugueux de
nationale 2 la belle aventure pour ce
monde de 22 ans
voici très belle aventure heureusement
je suis venu parce que je voulais pas
venir
bon après on m'a dit d'heure d'aller me
car c'était rêve tout ça et puis tu
venais déjà réaliser mes rêves face à
lille en huitièmes de finale même s'il
ne marque pas il fut avec jean philippe
grassaud le double buteur un poison
constant pour la défense des dogues qui
va craquer deux fois en cinq minutes
la porte des quarts de finale s'est
ouverte le rêve continue et
saint-etienne se profile à l'horizon des
vosgiens même pas peur
c'est qu'on va tout donner et puis si ça
passe ça passe ou ça casse ça casse de
michael biron le petit gars de ducos
cette saison 2019 2020 n'est décidément
pas comme les autres